hey guys I'm just McDonald today is the
7th of October you're watching games
what news at my first story of the day
will either make your day or scar you
for life so let's find out with the
future is here and it's absolutely
horrifying if NBA 2k15 space cans are
anything to go by in theory 2k15 the
ability to scan your face and create a
basketballer that looks just like you in
game is a pretty sweet option 2 K showed
off the feature working like a dream and
then our news writer Chris Pereira along
with a bunch of you tried it out with
results that were a little less in game
you and a little more mangled horror
movie villain however many of us are far
uglier than we thought all this tech is
a tad more finicky than advertised I
think games but user unreal 846 summed
up our reactions best with the age-old
adage kill it with fire send us the
creepiest face games you've seen so far
or one of your own if you've got your
hands on the game the super smash
brothers bits and pieces are rolling in
today the first of which is a release
date to jot on your calendar for the wii
u version the game will be on shelves
come November 21 in the US and december
five in europe nintendo are also
releasing two additional bundles one
that contains an amoeba figure that's
the little NFC plastic toys that are
compatible with a bunch of Nintendo
first-party titles and another that
comes with a gamecube controller adapter
so you can use that control pad you may
or may not still have with the wii u
december five will also bring a
standalone black GameCube controller and
a standalone controller adapter for wii
u two shelves as far as the 3ds version
of super smash brothers goes nintendo
have now sold 2.8 million copies
worldwide to date that covers retail and
digital units and make super smash for
3d asked one of the system's
best-selling games of all time the game
hasn't even been out for a week in the
West but has been available in Japan
since sep tember 13 we're at sold over a
million copies in its first weekend
Master Chief is certainly returning in
halo 5 but comments from the main
actor in the halo night for miniseries
suggests that perhaps he's not going to
be the main event agent Jameson Locke is
the protagonist of the upcoming mini
series which is tied into halo 5
Guardians lock is played by actor Mike
colter who told UK magazine x1 yeah I'm
a playable character in halo 5 once halo
the master chief collection is released
and then halo 5 comes out shortly
thereafter you're basically going to be
playing a game with me as the primary
character kulta also hinted that lock is
on a manhunt for master chief in halo 5
but we're yet to find out why or whether
he's a friend or foe to our
long-standing hero ask your question of
the day let me know in that comment box
if you reckon Master Chief should be the
primary protagonist of halo 5 or nut if
you're after more newsy bits and pieces
we've got a story on Diablo 3 console
patch and to follow up on our Assassin's
Creed unity story from yesterday that is
it for me today thanks for joining me
again as always and I'll see you same
time tomorrow